ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fariseo ci sono
molto molto molto concentrato ed
emozionato perché giocando per i cavoli
miei stamattina sono arrivato a diamante
3 questo vuol dire che se l'impegno
parecchio sono praticamente quasi a un
passo dal champion vi manca pochissimo
ma veramente poco per arrivare a
champion se aumento di ancora un po di
divisione ci posso arrivare ragazzi
della legge più sarebbe un sogno come
incredibile quindi parlerò di meno è nei
video parlerò di meno perché oggi voglio
non voglio intrattenere voglio
impegnarmi quindi commento la partita ma
cerco di concentrarmi sulla partita
perché se non la vinco di parte vediamo
di fare del nostro meglio e let's go che
è la partenza rimane un buona per niente
per attenzione ok
bellissimo se ci siamo il primo quello
di oggi bambolotti non era niente
richiesto come però importante che le
azioni si siano sviluppate nel modo
giusto
di la tua
perfetto siamo pagati in mano ma non
abbiamo segnato il 2 è stato orribile ma
saltato occhio non ti fa saltare zio
devine porca vacca no
bravo fabi così si gioca a bari edizione
così si gioca carchio stato si chiama
weasley l'altro ron dai dai dai che me
la sento champion mammamia anni di
giocate
che schifo mi dissocio e niente con loro
così pazzesco opposto bravo ripartiamo
fai fai 41 adesso il momento è il
momento zio è il momento ed è 4 a 12
minuti alla fine
bor volo ti prego l'estate mi sono visto
la docente ha lottato bene sì sì sì sì
sì sì sì dai ragazzi dai ragazzi costo
champion dai ragazzi ai ragazzi i pavidi
visione solo fargli leggere su ti prego
no è rimasta lì la divisione porca vacca
dai ragazzi amore far kim questo qua in
forma al gruppo va bene zio bella si
gioca bravo bravo bravo grosso master
let's go e non potrà farlo però sa in
anticipo l'ho giocata bene sto dicendo
era gol no e ancora gol di milanetto
effetto gli ha tagliato via toledo bravo
giovanni gross master bravo che sogno
quest'uomo che sogno ma donna un
compagno decente facciamo gruppo fino
alla morte per cortesia che sogno
finalmente uno che gioca porco demonio
che ci vuole ci vuole
3 a 1 manca un minuto tiro la teca non
ci seguito forte mai ragazzo non esiste
lui mica infine in porta all'inizio che
non è male però de pararla non c'è un po
di paura non riesca per noi importante
che non ti entra
benissimo io devo andare sul gruppo lame
prendilo tu diano no turbo quindi più
indietro sino fuga si riparte nella
merda
è successo da google
bellissimo electa l'attenzione seconda
vittoria di today
bene bene bene mi metti divisione iii
per favore ti prego niente dice sempre
di fermi non si muoverà mai pavana
ballali buona attenzione poi partire
frate parto indolore
questa bella non aver rimbalzato giusta
non dirmi che non sia importa ha
rimbalzato storta e quindi sono tutte 2
bravo è bravo si gioca così porca vacca
si gioca così un compagno che gioca
incredibile che un sogno
no il controllo sbagliato vabbè ho
sbagliato il controllo è schizzata
fortissima e dove sono
madonna madonna che voi stava uscendo
questi qua sta facendo l'incredibile noi
sono saltati kira kira bravo no che
fuori mannaggia per un niente fuori
vivai tiratura bene che cosa ha preso
tiro melo a zero si partì così papam
proprio in groppa però bellissimo gol
non si può dire un cacchio hanno fatto
un gol pazzesco bello madonna sta
togliendo lui
bello bello non avevo visto partire
quell'errore mio perché non devo stare
lì che è brutto rinvio non ho turbo
frate vero ci provo oddio melo saltato a
tutti per sbaglio non ti fa scavalcare
il sì bravo ed i suoi provarci
non è vero ci ha mica stradina sporca
che gol di stupido che abbiamo preso
come capo incastrati lì no
la loro stavolta cacchio danza 42
ci proviamo l'ultima ragazzi con
siamo in squadra con la fiamma di reg
vediamo gioca mai la fiamma di rugger
fammi vedere se riusciamo a raggiungere
stato champion sono stati 26 divisioni
una sola partita quel tiro non lo
aspettavo però porca put dai buona 0 per
loro dai facciamo rifare suo gol è
almeno iniziano a giocare
1 la palla rimane lì per favore toccano
la palla andata in porta
meno male e pazzesco da questo se i pali
credibili ok let's go bel gol
raga mi sono saltato uno e l'altro
demolito non è stato male come cosa boom
e l'altro via perfetto del blue note
ora una bella idea peccato togliti
lobato la vampata solo quando vai di
ripartire e non so non ci credo non sia
riuscita di partire dai dai frate dai
dai al 3 minuto utilizzato la faremo mai
va bene ci riproviamo ci proviamo dai
non ti preoccupare si dai siti fruci
possiamo ancora riuscire mancano due gol
a cacchio se la prendevo frate chicche
no no non puoi mancare quest'anno ne
vado ne vado che sfiga incredibile che
il sollecito bam parlo patron che
riguarda un soldato 10 ghiaccioli bravo
in più o meno tocca la va bene stata una
roba molto strano che bellissimo tratto
era stato assegnato gliela stavo
togliendo come ha fatto entrare st palla
scusate io ho consegnato qua come a lui
l'ha toccata ma tanto gliela stavo
togliendo perché vi sta arrivando
addosso incredibile
va bene rimasta la peccato era un bel
era gol se non bella fiamma vai
no peccato vabbè dai 10 ci abbiamo
provato ci ha provato ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto è stato comunque una
bella escalation cresce ognuna sei case
rimaste mediamente 3 adesso conclude
episodi scrive chiara ragazzi lasciando
un commento è come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo e ragazzi
[Musica]